for Steph and Clay if we switch Sports
who would be the better Duo oh man I've
seen Pat hoop he's actually pretty good
I haven't seen Travis play it but I can
imagine he's such a nice screen probably
a beast on the boars and a try hard it's
a different world in this football World
anybody can just pick up a ball and make
sure they hit a few you know jump shots
and get to the rack I personally think
me and Pat got the hoop skills I'm a 3md
type of guy man I can be a wing Defender
and knock down some shots man I got Gabe
like Draymond just out there just
playing my role baby who's playing
quarterback and who's playing receiver
amongst me and everybody you got the
height and the length so I feel like you
being a wide-out would be the better I'm
a quarterback you know I had one year of
high school football under my belt
ability to read the progressions is
pretty solid I can't say the same for
Steph now you play quarterback and I'll
play special teams
I've seen Steph throw the ball one time
so he might have a arm what come on man
I got the height of Tom Brady in the arm
of like Chad Pennington combination
nobody has said ever but uh